this video of Salmons gone viral over a
million hits on YouTube breaking that
tackle but guess what
Sam's a girl I came back from school my
brother was like running out to music
Sam Sam all these TV shells are calling
your favorite Sam Gordon is probably the
most fearless girl that I've ever met
she showed that girls can't do anything
that boys can do and sometimes even
better so I was speaking at a school
assembly and I was like how many girls
in here would want to play tackle
football and it seemed like all the
hands in the room went up that just kind
of sparked the idea like there is a real
demand for growth to play tackle
football I thought you know one of the
things that Sam could offer is the
ability to promote it Sam Gordon she
paved the way I really think for the
youth girls football she is the face of
our league she's a perfect
representation for the girls football
movement and she's a great person to
help us get this started there was a
flyer I opened it up and I said hey they
have a girl's tackling and she'd already
been playing football so I called her
and I said hey do you want to play girls
tackle football and she's like yeah I
started something up and down she's like
are you okay I was super excited first
thing I did when I found out was pretty
much texted all my friends saying that I
was going to be tackling everybody three
weeks is what we had to prepare for the
first game we were able to get plays
tackling everything done it just clicked
I think as the girls League girls and
you have more girls who have plates it's
just going to be just as competitive as
boys League our quote for the Utah girls
Tucker football league let's play it
like a girl it meant to be confident in
yourself and to do what you love and not
care what anybody else thinks now you
look back and say gosh everything they
did knows five games is setting that
standard now going forward you know you
can't take away what these girls have
done I want to play football for as long
as I can I really hope this league gets
national because I want other girls to
get the chance to play football this is
kind of the last frontier for girls
sports to expand and get into high
schools and colleges what Sam did for
the country is she showed other girls
that football is a girl's sport too and
that's why that league is thriving and
that effect will butterfly across the
country what Sam has accomplished is
inspiring she won't take no for an
answer and really be that driving force
behind girls tackle football
I'm hoping to girl the girls choco
Pahlavi as I get older so like when I'm
in high school there will be a high
school team when I'm in college there
will be a college team and when I'm
older there will be a professional girls
soccer football league like the NFL and
that that's what I want for future
tackle football for girls